hey guys greg here just on the internet
again
saw more memes and more gifts going
around
of baron zemo from episode three of
falcon in the winter soldier dancing
and look i know it's not a popular
opinion
but i just don't get what the big deal
is when john and i were doing a reaction
to it we noticed it we saw it happen i
guess
we didn't point it out because it
doesn't seem like it was a big deal all
the weird things we've seen him do this
whole episode to him dancing seems to
just fit within character and it
wasn't bad dancing it didn't even seem
that goofy to me but
everyone just seems to be losing their
mind over it and i i just don't get what
the big deal is i feel like it's being a
little bit overblown i know maybe you
guys can explain we're like
john john what do you what do you think
john john
john john what dude
what the hell are you doing dude marvel
just released an hour of zemo dancing
[Music]
dude i didn't see it before but i think
i get it now i love me too
i mean you just can't put it in words
but it works
perfect perfect so ouch